[موسيقى]
القاهرة فريدة من نوعها لأنه
لا يمكن التنبؤ بحب المصريين للاستمتاع
بالرقص فهم يحبون
الموسيقى ، قلب مصر وروحها مبنية على
الرقص ، هذه أرض الشكوك التي تخجل
من تناول الرقص الشرقي
أنا سلطان الأول.
الرقص المصري الراقص له أشكال مختلفة ،
فهناك الرقص الشرقي الكلاسيكي الحديث
في المعاصر ، ولكن بعد ذلك هناك
شيء خاص جدًا لدينا
يطلق عليه إنه هالة ،
وهي في الأساس المنطقة التي تلتقي فيها
جميع المساجد في القاهرة ، وهذا
قصر خشبي كان عليه.  تم بناؤه في القرن الخامس عشر الميلادي ،
حيث اعتاد أن يكون كارافانسيراي
حيث كان تجار الحرير وتجار التوابل
يجتمعون ويستخدمونه
الآن كنوع من الخلفية لعرض تانودا.
لديهم الأزياء الملونة التي يصنعونها
ومنطقة خاصة في القاهرة تسمى EMEA
، لقد حولوها حقًا إلى
فن أداء أنا متحمس
للرقص بشكل عام ، لذلك أجد أي نوع من
الرقص حيث  لقد تم رفع مستوى ople
روحيًا ، وأجد
أن الراقصين مدربين تدريباً جيدًا ومتميزين للغاية لكونهم مميزين للغاية ،
فهم يقومون بعدد مذهل
من الدورات ،
إنها ممارسة رائعة تم بناؤها
من هذه الأرض ، لذا فهي مجرد شيء
نتشاركه جميعًا
[موسيقى]